everyone's dealing with some stuff
everybody everyone's dealing with some
stuff you are I am everybody the human
side like this this is what you don't
see a lot you only see oh my gosh my
wife and I never argue our life is great
my hell I have no problems I'm great I'm
you know you know you do god cancer
doesn't come to me I give cancer cancer
because of this all that's great
and then we're human beings okay and
then we're human beings and everyone's a
human being no one is expecting you to
be a god no one is but at the same time
every family needs somebody that's
willing to be the strength be the
backbone but even that person I told
this to the guy that just lost his
fiancee
I told him I said listen man you can't
explain what it is to lose somebody you
love especially the girl that you're
gonna marry one day I said you got to
cry cry as much as you can life is life
so moral the story tonight everybody
watching this I guarantee if I told you
to put your problem here everybody would
post a bunch of problems on the comments
section everyone's dealing with some
stuff everybody everyone's dealing with
some stuff you are I am
everybody's and to every part of yours
is the biggest mine to use like to the
person s corner was the biggest but
what's made me gain me sanity to go
through this stuff I've always brought
it back and said whatever I'm going
through nothing is more painful then
somewhere in the world a parent lost
their child that they could have done
something about that's painful
you know I try to get to that state to
be able to control my own paint now loss
is a different story losses loss because
it's permanent until you know depending
on your faith in what you believe in but
anyways so tonight's message was a
little bit more about fears I don't want
to go be a downer with you but I think
sometimes we need to talk about this
kind of stuff because life is life you
know we don't talk a lot about this
stuff and I'm not giving it to you from
a standpoint of feeling sorry for
anybody I don't want you to feel sorry
for me have a very good life believe me
to me I feel like the last 27 years 28
years since I've been in America been on
vacation because I used to live in Iran
got bombed on God knows at any given
moment and I lived in Germany at a
refugee camp I got stabbed as a kid at a
refugee camp I got a scar and all this
other stuff and to me you know America
to me I'm living I'm living I'm living
in heaven so I keep saying it's heaven
on earth so don't feel bad for me I'm
good I'm good
I'm good
you